-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Tomorrow is election day,
which means President Biden's
impeachment trial, I guess,
starts on Wednesday.
[ Laughter ]
Former president Trump
is reportedly planning
to formally announce
his presidential campaign
on November 14th.
No word yet on his choice
for V.P.
or First Lady.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Barack Obama
and Donald Trump
held separate rallies over
the weekend in Pennsylvania.
Obama campaigned
for John Fetterman,
and Trump campaigned
for 2024.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee Chair
Sean Patrick Maloney said
in an interview yesterday
that Democrats will maintain
control of Congress and added,
quote, "We're not perfect,
but we are responsible adults
who didn't attack the Capitol."
Not exactly a high bar.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats are like the stepdad
of political parties.
They may be lame,
but at least they're not the guy
who walked out on you.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, I'm here!"
Yesterday was the end of
daylight savings time,
in case you were wondering
why these all feel
more like 1:30 in the morning
jokes.
[ Light laughter ]
The New York City marathon
was held yesterday,
and Kenyan runner Evans Chebet
was the men's champion
with a time of 2 hours,
8 minutes, and 41 seconds.
2 hours, 8 minutes,
and 41 seconds --
the fastest anyone has ever
gotten from Staten Island
to Central Park.
[ Laughter ]
At a rally in Pennsylvania
over the weekend,
former president Trump
called Florida governor
Ron DeSantis, quote,
"Ron DeSanctimonious."
Has anyone ever been worse at
coming up with nicknames?
Imagine Trump in "Top Gun."
People, people,
I know we all love Maverick,
but I think I got one
that beats it.
Are you ready?
Everybody ready?
"Airplane Guy."
That's right,
former president Trump
referred to Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
as Ron DeSanctimonious,
which is a risky move for Trump
because that's six syllables.
[ Laughter ]
A J.C. Penney location in
Pennsylvania temporarily closed
last week after a deer wandered
into the store.
Even crazier, a couple weeks
ago, a shopper wandered in.
[ Laughter ]
He's asking what aisle
stuff's in.
Over 50 students in El Paso,
Texas,
may have to retake the S.A.T.
after their answer sheets
flew out of a UPS truck
and were either lost
or destroyed.
The students are calling
the incident disheartening,
regrettable, disconcerting,
or irksome.
[ Laughter ]
Astronomers predict that
a total lunar eclipse
will occur tomorrow.
So, if you look outside
and the moon turns red,
Don't worry, it just means
Dr. Oz won his Senate race.
[ Light laughter ]
That's what the prophecy
foretold.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the makers of
Miller Lite this week
will offer a Christmas tree
keg stand.
And if you're wondering
what Santa's bringing you --
AA pamphlets.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.